hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
have you tried the resident evil 3 demo
yet you should its apocalyptically gray
and totally free to play during your
time in Raccoon City there are 20 secret
bobbleheads to discover and destroy I'll
tell you now the reward isn't great
basically you'll get points from
Capcom's Resident Evil Ambassador
Program which could lead to early access
and betas of future re titles but I'm
really here because I'm addicted to
collecting things and I hope you are too
so here's all twenty resident evil 3
demo bobbleheads and note all
bobbleheads carry over between
playthroughs so don't feel like you have
to get all these in one go just have fun
with it if you ready let's do this after
the initial cutscene venture up to the
ground level the first bobblehead is in
plain sight on a table before you exit
once you arrive outside make your way
over to the ambulance on the right hand
side for another bobblehead bobblehead
number 3 is a secret that must be
triggered it will appear here on the
roof of the donut shop just in front of
the oversized donut to trigger it turn
back around and look for a red car in
the toy store behind that is a poster
for those bobble heads look at this for
around 10 seconds for the magic to
happen turn back around and look the
bobblehead has spawned in shoot it
continued right and trigger the cutscene
with Carlos immediately swivel to your
left and you'll see 3 zombies at the
fence just behind them is a fourth
bobblehead below its face off next make
your way over to the stairway leading
down to the donut shop I've taken out
most of zombies in this playthrough to
make it easy to follow at the foot of
the stairs turn back around and looky
here
bobblehead number 5 turn left and follow
the metal walkway right at the top
you'll see on top of the substation a
nodding doll which is number 6 oh and as
an FYI here lower the ladder nearby it
will make escaping nemesis far easier in
future retrace your steps on the metal
walkway but this time stay right and go
into the room with
safe the code is nine one eight if you'd
like the optics for your pistol the
bobble head in here is hiding on the
shelving unit be careful though there's
a zombie in here who's super quick
bobblehead eight and nine are very close
continue through the next few doors and
you'll exit onto the street but don't go
any further
instead look up and you'll see another
bubble head waiting to be shot the ninth
collectible is also here just turn to
your left
and on top of the building with the neon
signs is bobblehead nine easy claps now
onto bobblehead 10 but while here we're
going to do a little prep work for
future secret bobbleheads pick up the
high-grade gunpowder it's essential that
you do not combine this with regular
gunpowder we need to make Magnum ammo to
trigger another bobblehead but more on
that a little later around the next
corner is a dead zombie he's laying on
top of yet another secret bobblehead
but we can't get that just yet so
remember this spot the one we actually
came here for is here exit the pharmacy
and stick to the right and enter this
building you'll stumble across the whole
pipe but do not grab it yet if we pick
that up it will trigger more zombies to
spawn in and the nemesis will become
active and remember he's literally
unkillable so don't bother picking this
up not just yet anyway going to the room
with and straight away on your left is
the bobblehead exit the building and
continue into the donut shop immediately
turn right and hiding next to the
microwave is bobblehead number 12 before
leaving the donut shop go to the back
room which is also a safe room and drop
off any unwanted items here be sure to
grab the bolt cutters
we need those next exit the donut shop
and head straight over to the locked
fence use your bolt cutters but after
doing so three zombies will be activated
the first one is on the right and the
next two around the corner fake them out
and destroy the barrel to stay super
safe
round the corner is the bobblehead he's
hiding in little cubbyhole here you can
also grab some shotgun shells but I
recommend the grenade if you have the
inventory space now we're going all the
way back through the donut place and up
the steps turn right to stumble across
another locked up star use those bolt
cutters again the bobble head here is
sat just by the tilt or the cash
register
remember the Gunpowder we picked up
earlier well now in this star we're
going to continue working on that hidden
bobble head just on the shelves is
another batch of high-grade gunpowder
pick it up and combine it with the one
we picked up earlier on to craft Magnum
ammo from here we are going all the way
back to the start of the game to see
Victor when we get there he says this
the combination of the Magnum ammo we
just made and talking to Victor has
spawned in yet another bobble head but
while we're here there's one we can get
nice and easy go towards the blocked
exit of the subway for another cheeky
bobble head on the opposite platform
that's fifteen five more to go back on
the Main Street head up to the roof
section if you knock down the ladder
this is much easier and much quicker
you'll notice a zombie has been moved
and look what's beside him bobble head
sixteen okay so those are the bobble
heads we can grab without triggering
nemesis but for the last four we need to
get him in play it's unavoidable
so Trek all the way back down to grab
the hose pipe and remember to grab any
other munitions you can especially the
grenades they're bloody great venturing
through the donut shop and we will see
nemesis take out your grenade
immediately and toss it this will knock
the nemesis about 30 seconds and it also
counts towards another secret bobblehead
we're already working on but we'll get
to that soon while he's down - run
straight past him up the stairs turn
left and then a quick right into the
fiery alley don't worry about nemesis
here he will not follow you now here's
the tricky part this is the very end of
the demo and if we move too far forwards
the game will end not a big deal because
we can replay but here is what is
the corner another bobblehead do you see
it well keep right and slowly nudge
forward until you have a clear line of
sight shoot and slowly back up to stay
in your current playthrough that makes
seventeen at this point another random
zombie has spawned into the demo he's
found at the other end of the street
you're on minding his own business he
should be a one-shot kill
but the real pressure comes from the
nemesis's presence once you've offered
the zombie go back to the pharmacy the
one with the dead cops inside he's now
alive but he's also unveiled another
bobble head shoot it for number 18
okay the last two dolls are
combat-related
the first requires 25 perfect dodges on
any enemy use zombies if you want I'll
get used to the attacks of nemesis to
get this done super quickly oh and don't
worry if you die the dodges carry over
and you can also select easy mode to
make the last bubble head a doddle
because we get the auto rifle
anyway after finishing all the dodges
get over to this police car around the
back of the donut shop near the alley we
cut open a zombie will fall out of the
door allowing us to find the penultimate
bobblehead and finally the last
collectable is all about knocking
nemesis we must knock him down three
times in the same play through here's a
thing to remember
you'll know when he's legitimately taken
down as Nemesis will pose with his hand
in the air beforehand the grenades I
told you to take will knock him
instantly and so do the barrels if you
have any left in your world other than
that you just gotta shoot him in the
heart until you see that animation if
you are unassisted difficulty this is a
breeze but it's still way more than
possible on standard difficulty once
complete another police car this time on
the top Street is activated and once the
door opens hit the final bobblehead oh
yeah they're zombies tax be careful now
it's simply a case of completing the
demo get to the fiery alley unleash the
water and walk forward demo completed
and 20 bobbleheads found well done you
deserve the accolades GG so there we
have it how addicting are collecting
collectables
remember don't feel like you have to get
all these in one playthrough with all
stacks apart from knocking nemesis three
times please let me know your thoughts
on this demo and thank you to those
people who contributed to the reddit I
could not have finished this list
without those last two being told I
really appreciated those guys they're
awesome anyway I'd love to know what you
think of this game are you getting it
should I play it on the channel please
let me know I am Adam from PlayStation
granade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time